in what remains of the airport in
tacloban crowds are waiting to escape
the nightmare
some have been here for days trying to
leave there's no hope so we have to get
up get out of this place
only about 150 people can board each of
the scarce flights out of the disaster
zone the military has said the priority
is to evacuate children the sick and the
elderly the others are forced to remain
often without the most basic necessities
i feel bad for my child because we don't
even have any water she says
most people can't leave and most of the
aid cannot get through there is a
shortage of trucks and many roads are
impassable
in desperation survivors have turned to
looting eight people were crushed to
death when thousands of people stormed a
rice warehouse and a wall collapsed
the government has deployed troops to
maintain order
but the authorities in tacloban are
struggling to cope
normally we're able to help people but
all our means of transportation have
been destroyed
we completed the mass gravesite
yesterday afternoon so we can bury many
of our dead
the stench of corpses hangs in the air
and the risk of disease increases as
each day passes without clean water
supplies
the sense of despair is growing unless
water and food are distributed soon the
chaos will worsen